Prepare for extreme conditioning and self-sacrifice...
...to join one of the most valued professions in the world.
You will need: Education, strength and stamina, and bravery.
Optional: Military service.
Step 1: Educate yourself about firefighting...
...by reading books and asking questions of firefighters.
Step 2: Achieve a high school diploma or GED...
...by the age of 18 to qualify to become a firefighter.
Online firefighting programs accommodate those trying to change careers.
Step 3: Maintain superior physical condition through rigorous exercises...
...to prepare for firefighting demands.
Step 4: Prepare for and take written fire department exams.
The test can be taken multiple times.
Step 5: Register for and pass a medical exam and drug screen.
Firefighters are often certified medical technicians,...
...so look for CPR classes and emergency training.
Step 6: Complete firefighter training, including prevention, technique,...
...hazardous material education, and emergency medical procedures.
Step 7: Complete the department's probationary employment, which is three to six months,...
...and you will be a full-fledged firefighter.
Did you know?
A recent survey found firefighting to be the most respected career in America.